this is who I am
join me it's crazy because obviously
this is a free-form event but your days
are numbered off reform a little oh I
know it's bittersweet but honestly I'm
so happy to be here to celebrate the
last season of Shadowhunters because it
is truly I believe our best season yet
the show has had so much time to really
form its own world and the world has
become a character itself so it makes
the show so much richer and and you just
kind of it's kind of sitting and it's
its own richness with this place it's so
rich I mean what has it meant to you
this experience because you guys have
told some really amazing important
stories but in the guise of something
really fun and entertaining to watch
well absolutely and I think that's
what's so wonderful about all these
supernatural shows and why people flock
to them is because it allows people to
look at their own issues and their own
struggles in an objective way and
through these characters that are going
through inherently human things even
though most of the time as in this case
on Shadowhunters none of them were
actually human right so you know who
doesn't want to believe in magic and
fairy tales and all the legends being
true that's so amazing though right it's
like wait what are you yeah well I now
having gone to so many Comic Cons and
talked to so many fans it's truly
incredible to hear all of these stories
and the fact that I get to do what I
love for a living and it affects someone
in a positive way somewhere in the world
it's the best gift I could have been
given what do you want to say to those
hardcore diehard fans because they are
right or die with you guys and I know
they're bummed that you guys are ending
the show well I have to say the biggest
thank you and that you guys are the
legacy of Shadowhunters you will be the
ones to continue on this love for the
story and these characters with us and
that will never ends just because there
are no more new episodes of the show
that doesn't mean that this family this
beautiful positive space for people to
feel loved and accepted has to go away
that will continue to grow and exist and
that's beautiful and now you're actually
going to now you're being embraced by a
whole nother fan group fandom aro what's
that been like for you it's been pretty
amazing to be honest I'm so thankful
that the arrow cast and crew and fandom
has been so welcoming and I love this
character Mia's pretty kick-ass and it's
it's fun to sort of follow in the
footsteps of people like Stephen Amell
and Emily BETT Rickards and all of those
people who have made
this world so great and and left kind of
a legacy for me to pick up
[Music]